um I have an incredible story for you
here
this is a story not only of of uh
potential domestic violence sadly but
also yet again of the projection that is
they are going to commit voter fraud we
have now learned of a man whose wife is
missing and he is a suspect in her
disappearance
who has pled guilty to Casting her
ballot for Trump in 2020. this is the
voter fraud that they claim exists
exclusively on the left and yet law
enforcement seems to only be able to
find Republicans committing voter fraud
the hill reports man with missing wife
pleads guilty to Casting her ballot for
Trump in 2020. a man who was tried in
connection to his wife's disappearance
pleaded guilty Thursday to submitting a
fraudulent ballot on her behalf for
Trump during the 2020 election this is
Barry more few who said to law
enforcement he figured all these other
guys are cheating my wife Suzanne would
have voted for Trump so I'm going to
submit a ballot for her
the defendant was arrested in May of
2021 but was already in police custody
because of his suspected role in his
wife's disappearance okay the suspicion
is he killed his wife
morphew was offered a plea deal allowing
charges of attempting to influence a
public servant and elections offense to
be dropped if he plea pled guilty to the
forgery charge he faces a year of
supervised probation for the charge
uh the murder case against Barry morphy
was dismissed without prejudice after
Suzanne morphy's body was unable to be
located so understand that we have no
particular reason to think he didn't
kill his wife there just was no body and
in this particular case there was not
enough of a circumstantial case
sometimes you see murder cases go
forward with nobody
uh sometimes you even see guilty
verdicts with nobody but in this case
there was no such case to be made
Suzanne morphew disappeared in May of
2020 and has not been recovered however
law enforcement said last year they
believe they are close to discovering
the victim's body think about that he
said to law enforcement listen uh
everybody else is cheating I know my
wife would have voted for Trump so I
decided to submit the vote for her
anyway that's a crime okay uh maybe the
wife didn't really want to vote for
Trump and he killed her and then voted
for Trump in her name
maybe we don't really know understand
the projection that is constantly
happening Republican leaders and Trump
spend 2020 saying there is massive fraud
Happening by by democrats and so some
Republican voters say screw it if the
Democrats are going to cheat we're going
to cheat too
and then law enforcement shows up and
says we don't find any Democrats doing
this we only are able to find
Republicans doing this some to quote
test the system and some because they
are just genuinely committing voter
fraud the very voter fraud that they say
it is the left that is that that uh is
being committed by the left these people
are incredible and if they are allowed
to do it again they will and if they're
able to succeed we're really screwed
many people are shocked when their
identity is stolen but it's actually one
of the fastest growing crimes in the U.S
I've dealt with it it's a terrible
feeling and that's why I now protect
myself with aura one of our sponsors
Aura monitors email addresses passwords
social security number bank accounts
credit cards and I can set it up to
instantly get an alert on my phone if
something happens and then Aura goes
through the process of fixing it as well
Aura also does things like make sure no
one's opening up bank accounts or credit
cards in your name Aura takes all the
tools you need to protect all of your
accounts and devices puts them in one
easy app Identity Theft Protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com Pacman you
can try Aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
I found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below